madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition près de cent mille personnes à
paris pour la techno parade sous le
soleil et sous les décibels le défilé
des chars avant le concert géant à la
nation invité de ce journal au milieu du
cortège jack lang aux états unis
l'humiliation de bill clinton c'est
lundi que la télévision diffusera le
témoignage du président une majorité des
américains désapprouvent
politique avec le discours de philippe
sega qui donne de la voix dans sa ligne
de mire notamment le pacte de solidarité
un sou mariage dit également nicolas
sarkozy les journées du patrimoine où
l'histoire d'amour de millions de
français qui se pressent dans les
quelques 13 mille monuments historiques
est ouvert au public depuis le début de
l'après-midi les décibels raisonne sur
les pavés de paris capitale de la techno
ambiance de carnaval message de
tolérance et de respect des autres
un cortège de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de fans pour cette techno
parade qui a désormais droit de cité
jérôme laurent thomas sénécal ils ont
des tenues délirantes futuriste
multicolore est pour eux un seul credo
danser danser et encore danser sur le
rythme binaire des musiques
électroniques paris vit aujourd'hui un
événement musical exceptionnel plus de
cent mille personnes ont défilé cet
après-midi dans les rues de la capitale
pour un concert géant de techno un rêve
éveillé pour tous les fans de cette
musique du troisième millénaire une
libération après des années de
frustration
la techno parade à bord
très protocolaire mans remercier jacques
landes qui va permettre à tous les
jeunes dramatiser un peu ce mouvement
techno bondir sur la techno c'est pas
seulement de la dronne ces deux jeunes
qui s'amusent tard en tapant carnoët
bizarrement c'est génial il ya encore
tant elle a fait le bonheur la techno
parade c'est de la sueur pour danser des
heures et surtout beaucoup de bruit des
décibels qui nous charme pas forcément
toutes les oreilles
je suis contre la techno contre la
musique parce que ça fait du bruit
voilà ça laisse à penser
moi je suis prête à sauter comme moi si
j'étais jeune ça comme ça
alors la techno serait elle à l'origine
d'un conflit de génération
pas si sûr en tout cas ils n'ont pas
fini de sautiller ces jeunes primitif
grâce à cette techno parade les musiques
électroniques sont enfin sortis de
l'anonymat s'est très bien passé ça va
largement de la nos espérances a priori
plus de cent mille personnes vraiment le
public
au delà de la techno on voit vraiment de
tout des gens très différents donc c'est
vraiment une super fête et ce soir la
fête continue les participants sont
arrivés place de la nation ou à méga
concert est organisé avec les plus
grandes stars de la scène techno c'est
précisément antoine cormery vous aident
en direct de la place de la nation le
cortège est donc arrivé ici après un
parcours de plusieurs kilomètres
énormément demandé une foule
impressionnante
oui par moments ça faisait penser à un
petit peu à ce que ce que l'équipe de
france avait pu vivre sur les champs
elysées en les remontant après sa
victoire en finale
c'est un vrai succès cent vingt mille
personnes selon les estimations de la
police
c'est vrai que la techno est un
phénomène nocturne habituellement et qui
pourront connaître les savoirs ou sohu
récupérer les invitations pour
fréquenter les les fêtes est là pour la
première fois monsieur tout le monde a
pu découvrir dans la rue dans les rues
de paris et en plein jour ce qu'était
vraiment que cette musique techno
commence à sedan c'est comment il
fallait être habillé pour être dans le
ton donc c'est un vrai succès de ce
point de vue là et puis un succès qui a
été aussi servi par un temps magnifique
tout l'après-midi au tout paris de ce
point de vue là johnny hallyday peut
être un petit peu jaloux en tout cas la
fête est loin d'être terminée et la nuit
promet d'être longue
ben vous l'entendez sûrement boum boum
c'est très très fort en ce moment en
place de la nation il ya beaucoup de
monde c'est noir de monde et puis les
plus grands dj européen sont ici sur
place pour donner un concert
gratuit il ya notamment laurent garnier
qui est à l'olympia cette semaine car le
coach rayon j'en passe et d'autres la
crème des dj européen
et puis ça va continuer longtemps ici et
aussi dans bon nombre de boîtes
parisiennes collaboratrice merci antoine
et nous rejoindront la techno parade
dans le dernier tiers de ce journal et
nous recevrons jack lang précisément
direct de la place de la nation
aux etats unis les sondages effectués
après la décision du congrès de diffuser
la télévision de témoignages de bill
clinton laisse apparaître une certaine
lassitude de l'opinion publique
un scandale qui n'en finit pas 70% des
américains
selon le new york times ont désapprouvé
le feu vert du congrès reste que le
parti républicain en campagne ne désarme
pas philippe gassot à la maison blanche
c'est un peu la veillée d'armes avant le
choc de lundi la diffusion des fameuses
cassettes vidéo enregistrée par le
président et transportés ici sous bonne
escorte
les images qui seront dévoilés au grand
public montreront un président
embarrassé confus procédurier colérique
enfin des documents que les républicains
ont de très bonnes raisons de vouloir
divulguer vite car il pourrait bien
écornée les excellents sondages dont
bénéficie bill clinton et c'est ça le
but de l'opération
le vice-président réagi j'ai appris que
tout cela c'était décidé sur des bases
partisanes si c'est vrai il faut que ça
change
l'examen impliqué des preuves la
présomption d'innocence la lecture des
rapports qui devait se faire sereinement
au congrès prennent aujourd'hui des
allures de pugilat politique
fini le fair play le pluralisme c'est la
lutte au couteau que redoutait tant la
présidence je pense que tout ce qui a
été fait jusqu'à présent est destiné à
nuire et à humilier au maximum le
président la très républicaine coalition
chrétienne réunis à washington se frotte
les mains le scandale c'est du pain béni
quand la procédure de destitution va
commencer monsieur clinton sera chassé
de ses fonctions
déjà les télévisions annonce la
diffusion des caisses est stone et bill
clinton ne semble pas craindre une
baisse dans les sondages qui pourrait
pourtant lui être fatale ce que l'on
redoute ici c'est de voir la machine
politico judiciaire s'emballer et
devenir incontrôlable mais à travers la
publication du rapport kenneth starr et
maintenant cette diffusion télévisée du
témoignage du président c'est toute
l'autorité morale du premier personnage
de la nation qui est en jeu je me repose
de voir comment réagissent les enfants
des écoles avec ce reportage dans un
collège de virginie dont l'ordre du jour
était le mensonge et la morale maryse
burgot ils ont entre 9 et 12 ans ils
sont où l'amérique de deux mois nous
sommes dans une école d'alexandria une
banlieue de washington de classe moyenne
l'instituteur parle aujourd'hui de
cynisme données citées est ce que
quelqu'un sait ce que ça veut dire être
né spontanément et sans qu'on leur
demande c'est jeune américain évoque
alors les mensonges de leur propre
résidence
je ne le comprennent pas c'est sa vie
privée
il a juste menti pour essayer de s'en
sortir même si c'est sa vie privée
les quand même marié il a une fille elle
en tire ce n'est pas bien
qui que l'on soit surtout pour un
triangle et c'est bien le dilemne
aujourd'hui de milliers de parents
américains bill clinton devrait
aujourd'hui à leurs yeux représenter un
modèle pour la jeunesse
au lieu de cela ce couple nous explique
à la sortie de l'école qu'ils ne
regardent plus les informations à la
télévision avec les enfants la
révélation des détails sur la vie
sexuelle du président leur paraissant
inadmissible sur le petit écran etc
c'est vraiment très gênant car beaucoup
d'enfants sont suffisamment grands pour
son tout ce qui se passe alors en tant
que parent regarder ça met vraiment en
colère dans les jours qui viennent
ces enfants seront aussi à la télévision
le témoignage crucial de leur président
devant le grand jury avec entre autres
le moment où il apparaît furieux et
finit par admettre sa relation avec
monica les risques selon instituteur de
notre classe cette diffusion est
proprement scandaleuse c'est moche je ne
sais pas quel moment nous avons perdu le
sens de la raison mais cela ne devrait
pas être diffusée à la télévision et le
grand déballage ne s'arrête plus les
enfants viennent ainsi d'apprendre que
le responsable de la commission
judiciaire du congrès chargée de statuer
sur la sphère clinton a eu lui aussi une
liaison extraconjugale aussi des pina
ferrer pris dans la tempête a fait
naufrage la nuit dernière le bilan est
lourd plus de 150 disparus les
recherches se poursuivent malgré les
difficiles conditions météo près de 300
rescapés ont été repêchés dans cette
zone qui se situe à une centaine de km
de manille et patrice romedenne
celui ci a dérivé pendant 12 heures et
pourtant le plus dur reste à faire
grimper impossible il est à bout de
force
un sauveteur vient à lui l'épaule les
deux hommes seront remorqués jusqu'au
rivage le plus proche mais nico lui
repart pour une énième tournée d'abord
repérer d'éventuels survivants ensuite
leur larguer des embarcations de
sauvetage dans lesquelles les rescapés
le visage noirci par le carburant du
ferry disparu s'entassent avant d'être
recueilli quatre bâtiments de la marine
de guerre philippines mobiliser un garde
côte également il ya les hélicos des
bateaux de pêche qu'importe le moyen
l'essentiel est de retrouver la terre
ferme où ne subsistent que la force de
pleurer les proches disparus dans le
naufrage
pendant qu'on évacue les victimes
quelques officiels disserte sur les
conditions de navigation exécrable la
nuit dernière des vents de 100 km par
heure il est vrai quand il faut ballet
la région depuis quelques jours le
président philippin lui s'est rendu sur
place
il annonce l'ouverture d'une enquête et
ils écoutent ce qu'on lui dit notamment
que le capitaine n'a pas donné l'ordre
d'évacuer le ferry ou encore que les
membres d'équipage se sont précipités en
premier dans la mer et l'ouragan qui
menace les antilles se dirigent
apparemment vers la martinique et la
guadeloupe
cet ouragan est baptisée georges les
vents sont violents ils atteignent pour
l'instant plus de 170 kilomètres à
l'heure en france nous en parlions il ya
quelques semaines un médecin accusé
d'euthanasie comparaissait pour la
première fois lors du débat public
devant le conseil régional de l'ordre
des médecins
une décision très attendue avant le
débat parlementaire qui devrait se
dérouler à l'automne sur la difficile
question de l'euthanasie tout à l'heure
le docteur dufault a été relaxé
christophe la rocca olivier combe
le conseil régional de l'ordre des
médecins après en avoir délibéré qui nie
avoir lieu de prononcer de sanction
disciplinaire à l'encontre du docteur
jean-paul du faux le docteur jean-paul
du faux est donc relaxé
les médecins ont statué sur la base d'un
seul critère celui de la déontologie
non jean paul dufau n'a pas failli en
pratiquant un acte d'euthanasie active
sur une patiente de 92 ans le chef de
service gériatrique d'un établissement
de séverac-le-château s'en était
expliqué publiquement le 29 août dernier
sa patiente et est hémiplégique dans le
coma est menacée par la gangrène et j'ai
pensé que d'arriver à 4h au bout de ce
délai de 24 heures elle n'était pas
décédée c'est alors que j'ai pris cette
audition si j'avais rencontré là parmi 1
seuls du membres de l'équipe une
opposition à ce geste réalisé si le
docteur du fond avaient agi en
concertation avec l'équipe médicale il
n'avait pas consulté la famille après sa
comparution 300 lettres de soutien
émanant de médecins étaient parvenus au
conseil bernard kouchner lui-même avait
pris position en faveur du médecin à 0
n'est nul doute que la relâche du
docteur dufau par ses pairs fera date
elle ouvre en effet la voie au
classement de la faire sur le plan pénal
le parquet de millau visiblement
embarrassé n'avait pas caché qu'il
attendrait la décision du conseil pour
ouvrir ou non une information judiciaire
pour homicide volontaire
un embarras qui pourraient subsister
chez les magistrates temps qu'un
véritable débat parlementaire n'aura pas
eu lieu sur la question de l'euthanasie
les élèves des grandes écoles ont repris
le chemin des cours pour remplacer le
bizutage dans les excès entamé ségolène
royal à interdire sa pratique
l'exemple d'un bizutage écolo et
intelligent les élèves ingénieurs de
l'école nationale de saint-etienne ont
passé le week end à nettoyer les ponts
et les décharges sauvages
didier guyot philippe évêques ont faussé
d'abord lire en bas à prendre la passe
et antirouille apprend passera la
peinture week-end bizutage pour la
nouvelle promotion de l'école
d'ingénieurs de saint-etienne ici pas de
défilé loufoque avec eux et sarine en
prix mais plutôt du travail d'intérêt
général
objectif de la journée poncet et peindre
en groupe quelques ponts rouillé du
village je préfère faire ça que mon 32e
de la farine et tout ça sur la tête par
tout cas je sais très bien parce que
c'est ce moment ça nous apprend the zoo
savoir ce qui est autour de nous mais
pas bien à l'école et non d'une vision à
l'extérieur une envie de rendre service
et une fibre écologiste qui séduit les
habitants
c'est sensationnel
c'est sympathique et puis ce après un
contact avec les jeunes citadins et les
ruraux
vous avez tous les bouts de plastique y
sont accessibles
outre les ponts les 150 élèves
ingénieurs sont ils ont également
nettoyé les décharges sauvages plastique
bois vieille carcasse machine à laver
les déchets seront ramenés un à un c'est
surtout pour faire prendre conscience
aux gens qu'il faut pas mettre les
déchets n'importe où surtout que
maintenant on a des ramassages organisé
et vraiment on a besoin que la mentalité
change et je pense qu'avec les jeunes on
va la faire changer
l'année dernière déjà l'école
d'ingénieurs de saint-etienne nettoyer
des risques cette année elle s'attaque à
la pollution terrestre n'est demain une
fois le travail terminé ce sera sport
collectif et détente à aix en provence
la nuit dernière deux hommes armés et
cagoulés ont volé sans arme de poing
dans un centre de tir considéré comme le
plus grand de la région de marseille
ils ont neutralisé sans violence les
employés sur place puis ont pris la
fuite
politique avec ce sondage ifop/journal
du dimanche la popularité de jacques
chirac reste stable en septembre à 62%
alors que lionel jospin baisse de deux
points par rapport au mois d'août 61%
le président du rpr philippe séguin
devant les militants du mouvement
gaulliste à paris dénoncé les méthodes
des intellectuels en chaises longues et
rejette le pacte de solidarité nicolas
sarkozy surenchéri en parlant de son
mariage roland sicard françois granier
au rpr l'ambiance est aux grands
sourires et aux poignées de main pas
question de se disputer même ceux qui
d'habitude met les pieds dans le plat
fonds motus et bouche cousue et dans le
parc de liste les rôles sont répartis
il ya d'abord nicolas sarkozy chargé
d'attaquer le gouvernement sur les
questions d'actualité aujourd'hui c'est
le pacs qui était en ligne de mire ce
même gouvernement qui ne pouvaient plus
d'argent pour que les familles et des
enfants est en train de nous expliquer
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres priorités que
de faire le pacs est de voter un nouveau
statut pour les couples homosexuels
philippe séguin lui se veut rassembleur
de l'opposition bientôt il dira s'il
veut rester président du rpr en
attendant il par le programme et refuse
de recevoir des leçons surtout sur la
question du front national sous couvert
de morale certains se livrent à une
grossière tentative de déstabilisation
de l'opposition républicaine
ainsi sommes-nous jour après jour sommet
de nous estime fier devant des
intellectuels en chaise longue
6e se sont trompés surtout de spa l'une
amoureux de marie philippe séguin
offensif philippe séguin qui sait
pourtant que le chemin de la reconquête
sera long et difficile
exemple alors que l'opposition affiche
son union elle n'est pas certaine de
réussir à constituer une liste unique
pour les élections européennes de l'an
prochain des élections qui constitueront
pour elle un véritable premier test pour
sa part alain juppé veut quant à lui
aussi le projet de pacte civil de
solidarité s'est prononcé contre une
parodie de mariage mais pour un texte
qui permettent des aménagements actuels
fin de citation du côté de l'udf
françois bayrou pour son discours de
clôture des journées parlementaires
jouent l'optimisme carole comment bruno
livertout
une rentrée qui a encore quelques airs
de vacances l'udf vient d'élire son
nouveau président et les parlementaires
tiennent résolument à afficher leur
bonne humeur
officiellement tous n'ont plus qu'un
objectif faire exister la nouvelle udf
et le calendrier pourrait bien leur
venir en aide avec la prochaine échéance
les élections européennes de juin
prochain
certains voient l'europe on porte
l'europe comme une croix dhombres nous à
l'udf nous sommes les héritiers du rêve
européen ne laissant à personne d'autre
que nous le soin de fixer les termes de
ce débat
laurent et l'udf pose déjà ses
conditions à une liste commune avec le
rpr que tous les candidats s'engagent à
siéger au parlement de strasbourg
l'europe où la bataille contre le pacs
autant d'occasions de remobiliser l'udf
notre udf l'automne est un printemps
nous avons trouvé le moment de la
remontée et ce moment il est elle pour
nous et pour l'opposition dans son
ensemble reprendre l'offensive c'est la
nouvelle stratégie de françois bayrou
pour tenter de rassembler enfin l'udf
l'université de rentrée de philippe de
villiers avec son mouvement pour la
france à ses côtés charles pasqua qui
n'avait fait aucune déclaration et
refaire le matin et qui réclament cet
après midi est à nouveau référendum sur
l'europe
quant aux élections européennes il est
pour l'instant trop tôt pour parler
d'une liste commune entre le mouvement
de philippe de villiers et l'association
de deux mois la france de charles pasqua
la fête des bleus blancs rouges sur la
pelouse de reuilly près du bois de
vincennes deux séances de dédicaces et
photos de famille jean marie le pen et
bruno mégret côte à côte devant des
plateaux d'huîtres de la trinité-sur-mer
image très médiatique que pour
réaffirmer dit jean marie le pen qu'il
n'ya pas de réconciliation puisqu'il n'y
a jamais eu de dispute à l'étranger
nouvel attentat en algérie 26 personnes
ont été déchiquetées hier après midi par
l'explosion d'une bombe artisanale 125
blessées dont 39 sont dans un état grave
l'engin était placé sur un marché de
tiaret
à plus de 300 km au sud ouest d'alger
et puis en allemagne à rostock le
rassemblement organisé par l'extrême
droite a réuni 4000 sympathisants le
crâne rasé
encadrés par d'importantes forces de
police ils ont défilé dans la ville
alors que parallèlement à deuxième
cortège de quelques 3000
contre-manifestants se réunissait tout
près de là dans cette ville où se sont
déroulés en 92 de violentes émeutes
racistes plusieurs dizaines
d'interpellations ont eu lieu cet après
midi à une semaine des élections le
champ si les loups de cole tente de
reconquérir l'allemagne de l'est
violemment touchée par le chômage
dans l'une des villes les plus
sinistrées de l'ex rda le chancelier a
essayé de faire entendre sa voix
reportage à bitterfeld philippe rochot
pierre moscovitch helmut kohl à la
reconquête d'une allemagne de l'est qui
progressivement lui a retiré sa
confiance à bitterfeld 30% de la
population a perdu son travail c'est la
ville la plus sinistrée de l'ancienne
rda qu'il doit partir disaient les
opposants qui brandissait même le
drapeau de l'allemagne communiste en
signe de révolte
le gouvernement il ne compte pas les
chômeurs qui reçoivent de l'aide mais
dans la région de petersfield une
personne sur trois n'a plus de travail
et vous allez voter pour qui on espère
que le spd remportera la victoire
beatles était la ville la plus polluée
d'europe à coups de milliards de marks
elle renaît de ses cendres au prix d'une
vague de licenciements
quarante mille ouvriers de l'industrie
chimique sont au chômage alors gerhardt
s'est réfugié dans le parti communiste
rénover le pds j'ai l'impression qu'on
ne veut pas vraiment la réunification
vous savez la différence entre l'est et
l'ouest est le résultat d'un tas de
choses
par exemple les gens ici gagne seulement
70% de ce qu'ils reçoivent à l'ouest et
ça fait grandir le complexe
d'infériorité
et pourtant le gouvernement paul
reconstruit bitterfeld et tente
d'effacer la pollution laissés par les
communistes des rares comme les autres
se jette dans la société de consommation
mais il votera quand même contre helmut
kohl la survie politique du chancelier
kohl dépendra donc en grande partie du
vote des allemands de l'est
un électorat instable qui restera sans
doute indécis jusqu'au bout mais qui
risque fort de sanctionner sa politique
vis-à-vis de l'ancienne allemagne de
l'est par un vote de protestation retour
à paris place de la nation pour la
grande fête techno dans un instant nous
parlerons avec jack lang qui fut l'un
des instigateurs de cet immense parade
mais d'abord voyant cette photo
instantanée de la fête tout au long du
cortège cet après midi antoine cormery
et valérie criton ont suivi la techno
parade
juché sur l'un des trente chars du crâne
du carnaval apparemment la fête
parisienne n'a rien à envier à la love
parade de berlin
vu ce qui les attendait dans l'après
midi un petit échauffement matinal
n'était pas inutile
14h place denfert rochereau
bienvenue à bord du camion paris berlin
un 38 tonnes
vaguement détourné de sa fonction
première mais du coup si ce n'est pas un
camion qu'est ce que c'est avec des
fleurs à craindre au contraire c'est la
pole c'est le pathos du pôle
un avion de rêve
objet de rêve certes mais servie par une
sono surpuissant 12000 watts dans les
amplis de l'arast os made in germany qui
a largement assouvi la soif des danseurs
les plus accros au milieu des trente
camions de la parade celui ci illustre
est donc sa manière l'amitié franco
allemande
deux associations allemandes est
d'ailleurs présente à la love parade et
on a voulu faire le pont entre la love
parade de berlin et la techno parade de
paris dont seize chars à boeufs
l'allemagne kehl à des dj des deux pays
se sont succédé aux platines l'occasion
était trop belle pour leur demander si
cette première parade parisienne n'était
pas un peu riquiqui en comparaison de la
monumentale parade de berlin
je ne trouve pas que citic ça c'est même
une grande parade à berlin il ya dix ans
on a commencé avec 300 personnes c'est
grand c'est beau c'est magnifique
après quatre heures de musique non-stop
les ambitions tu en arrives à la nation
pour faire place aux concerts géants
tous on or on vient profiter mes amitiés
franco allemande ou pas ces retards ne
sont pas mécontentes ça s'arrête
en marge de la parade différentes
associations comme celle de médecins du
monde ont finalement eu le droit de
s'installer le long du cortège leur rôle
agir de manière préventive sur la
toxicomanie
olivier les nizza franz haillan elles
sortent de leur boîte pour vivre au
grand jour leur rêve un rêve étoilé une
rave géante qui fait gigoter des
antennes de bonheur
mais pour arriver à l'extase les
insectes abuse parfois de petites
graines des pilules dont la consommation
est interdite par la loi pour lutter
contre les ravages de l'ecstasy la
police réprime médecins du monde
sensibilise des médecins qui propose aux
jeunes un contrôle rapide des produits
contenus dans les pilules une mission
critique et pour certains médecins du
monde entrave le travail de la police
l'accusé plaide non coupable
nous allons sur les événement non
autorisé parce que c'est là qu'il ya pas
de présence sanitaire c'est tout
deuxième reproche médecins du monde fait
l'apologie de la drogue coupable non
coupable nous ne faisons pas l'apologie
de la drogue nous faisons de la
prévention en un an l'association
analysé sur le terrain de 1200 pilules
certaines contiennent des hallucinogènes
des amphétamines parfois les médecins
sont incapables d'identifier la
composition chimique d'un cachet on leur
dit que c'est la roulette russe et qu'on
le sait qu'on est incapable de leur
donner la moindre information sur ce que
contient le produit dans un certain
nombre de cas il renonce tout simplement
l consommer mais parfois certains le pen
quand même mais certaines personnes ne
prennent quand même bien sûr médecins du
monde réclame un cadre légal pour
intervenir lors des rave parties afin
d'éviter les accusations de provocation
à usage de drogue
l'association se bat également contre
l'incompréhension d'une partie du public
ce type de prévention en matière de
consommation de drogue commence en
france que c'est quelque chose de
nouveau et que donc on retrouve d'une
certaine manière des critiques qui nous
avait été fait à l'époque on avait
commencé à distribuer des seringues
propres toxicomanes
la pilule du bonheur peut rapidement se
transformer en cash et du malheur les
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
participaient aux rêves ne sont pas tous
consommateurs de drogues chimiques mais
l'ecstasy est devenu un réel problème
sanitaire
gare aux hallucinations chaque langue
vous êtes en direct de la place de la
nation bonsoir vous êtes président de la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'assemblée
je dirais qu'en même temps vous êtes un
peu le bon génie de cette techno parade
cette réussite c'est un peu la route ce
soir
je suis en même temps transformée en
commentateur sportif comme vous le voyez
je réponds à votre question ce soir je
crois que beaucoup de gens ici
250000 je crois ressentons un grand
bonheur
la culture techno appartient à la
culture d'aujourd'hui
longtemps elle avait été mal comprise
rejeté écartée enfin elle est pleinement
reconnue et on sent ici un sentiment de
joie et pas seulement parmi les les
praticiens la techno aussi par le parc
parmi le grand public ont diabolisé la
techno mais sans être non plus hypocrite
la drogue dans les rave party est une
préoccupation majeure vous en convenez
jack lang comme c'est une préoccupation
majeure
partout à la société je crois que il ne
faut pas mélanger ou à jausiers techno
et et drogues les un problème d'ensemble
qu'il faut poser sur le plan national
avoir le courage de réunir les
toxicomanes les éducateurs les médecins
pour trouver des solutions pour le mieux
lutter contre les trafiquants et surtout
pour prévenir et pour guérir mais leur
revient à l'aspect artistique si vous le
permettez qu'elle plus importante
au delà de la reconnaissance de la
culture était clos c'est tout un message
de vie qui est transmis ici un message
d'ouverture un message de respect un
message d'amitié et ça a été ressentie
pas seulement par les jeunes mais par
toutes les générations et je crois
pouvoir dire que cette manif est
aujourd'hui est un peu une manifestation
de fondation vous vous souvenez à la
nation il y avait eu avec chauny ans
dans les années 60 un immense concert
comparables qui a été en quelque sorte
l'acte de fondation de la culture pop
mais je crois pouvoir dire que grâce
notamment à l'association technopol à
beaucoup de monde a beaucoup de bonne
volonté
ce soir c'est un petit peu l'acte de
fondation de la culture techno et
j'ajouterai enfin si vous le voulez bien
que le hasard du calendrier fait que le
même jour il y a la fête des monuments
historiques
cette célébration de la techno ce qui
veut dire que la culture d'un pays forme
un tout c'est à la fois l'histoire le
passé la mémoire vous êtes aussi le
présent et le futur
jack lang évidemment vous parlait très
bien de cette culture techno d'ailleurs
les fans de la techno vous ont adopté il
paraît même qu'ils vous ont donné un
surnom du sari lequel j'ai vu quelque
part
baby d'odjidja qui paye du mois c'est
très gentil de me faire agenouiller
alors revenons en plus sérieusement à
l'un des problèmes évoqués à travers les
rave parties il ya aujourd'hui dans les
préfectures de police des circulaires
qui considère que les rave parties sont
des rassemblements à haut risque est ce
que vous demandez ce soir la
modification de ses textes
disons que depuis des mois et des mois
je demande qu'elle soit réinscrite sinon
même abrogée et jean pierre chevènement
avec très gentiment reçu les délégués du
mouvement techno et s'était engagé à
faire une réforme
je crois pouvoir dire que
qu'indépendamment du texte après las le
succès de la manif et le jour d'hui la
circulaire et des méthodes de fait à
bouger dans les têtes et que à l'avenir
on accordera à cette culture comme aux
autres cultures de france
une vraie liberté merci jack lang
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions place de la nation et
j'imagine que vous allez continuer la
fête et la nuit sera sans doute que
longueuil
merci à vous revenez l'euro venait le
rejoindre à la nation journal
après je l'entends nouveau succès pour
les journées du patrimoine on attend
plus de 10 millions de visiteurs jusqu'à
demain soir partout en france monuments
historiques lieu de promenade des
propriétés privées sont ouverts
gratuitement au public démonstrations
cet après midi à la découverte de la
banque de france gérard dalmaz les
greniers la banque de france le coffre
fort national est aussi un trésor de
boiseries de peinture les citoyens
lambda peut s'y balader lors des
journées du patrimoine
en plus chez une ancienne banquière
alors comme j'ai jamais vu les pieds
avant que france samedi
normal de venir visiter un petit peu qui
a baigné ma vie tout le long de ma
carrière
fleuron de la maison la grande galerie
dorée en 16 135 à la baie l'heur de
plaire ou conseiller de louis xiii
un siècle plus tard l'un des fils de
louis xiv et de la montespan y ajoutera
les dorures à son goût en l'an 2000 la
décoration séduit également les enfants
j'aime bien parce que le visiteur est
aux anges
avec un tel raffinement 13000 monuments
sites démonstrations de métiers et
savoir-faire pendant ses 15e journées du
patrimoine l'impression et la sfi gîte
yves que nous sommes propriétaires de
ces palais
une décoration qui a été préservé pour
voir comment les gens vivaient
une époque antérieure et par quelque
chose qui a été conservé dans les temps
du moins de gens ont essayé de conserver
dans les bars clin d'oeil genre choc des
cultures ce n'est pas un concert est ici
il n'ya pas de disc-jockey croix des
petits champs avant de france techno
parade
c'est un tuyau percé mais mon égard y
trouve son compte comme quoi les lieux
d'argent font toujours recette ces
milliers de monuments historiques sont
entretenus resterait avec beaucoup de
savoir faire et de sacrifice à côté des
fonds publics il existe désormais des
entreprises privées qui associent leurs
noms à la réhabilitation et à la gestion
de ces sites comme le château de
valençay dans le val d'oise
gérard dalmas guillaume [ __ ] à la
tanière de talleyrand valence et était
peu à peu déserté depuis 96 le château
est revenu de 65 mille à 91 mille
visiteurs par an ce miracle n'est pas
arrivé en claquant les doigts
la belle demeure au bois dormant du val
de loire s'est réveillé grâce à la
politique de relance
exemple les animations avec des
comédiens le diable boiteux de napoléon
le mâle jambes et voici d'ailleurs son
appareillage reste la star du palais
face à la dégringolade de sa
fréquentation les propriétaires conseil
général de l'indre et groupama ont
confié la demeure à une maison privée
culture et développement questions au
directeur anciens du parc astérix est ce
que les vieilles paires se gère comme
une industrie
oui manifestement c'est un produit
touristique c'est un produit culturel
mais c'est un produit touristique
donc on est bien amenée à avoir la même
démarche
lorsque l'on gère un produit même le
plus culturel possible comme on est
amené à avoir une démarche de gestion
une démarche d' équilibre pour un site
qui soit de loisirs sans pièces des
meubles souvent historiques exemple la
table ronde sur laquelle talleyrand à
négocier lors du fameux congrès de
vienne 1815
valençay attire à nouveau les foules
d'ordinaire un château s'équilibre
financièrement à partir de cent mille
visiteurs ici grâce aux idées aux
investissements la gestion ne perdra
plus d'argent dès l'an prochain avec
seulement 95 mille entrées à 50 francs
talleyrand le génie tenait parfois les
rênes de la diplomatie depuis valence
est son ministère bis seigneur ces
dîners avec carême pour cuisinier il
était renommé dans toute l'europe
vous lancez une bonne journée en pays de
valence et valence n est plus un château
musée c'est un château vivant ainsi se
termine ce journal je vous en rappelle
les principaux titres plus de cent mille
personnes à paris pour la techno parade
sous le soleil et sous les décibels le
défilé des chars avant le concert géant
à la nation aux états unis l'humiliation
de bill clinton c'est lundi que la
télévision diffusera le témoignage du
président une majorité des américains
désapprouvent
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet beau temps de fin d'été de
master catherine ceylac reçoit françoise
fabian et jacques weber pour une journée
particulière mehdi et polémiques michèle
cotta aura comme invité marc blondel
je vous retrouve de ma dépresseurs merci
de votre attention
ex en fin de soirée sur france 2
tout